Про шалену підтримку - як на виборах до Верховної Ради торік - партія Володимира Зеленського нині може лише мріяти.
На місцевих виборах політсила президента, що має монобільшість у парламенті,
показала не дуже переконливий результат.
За даними екзитполів, у найбільших містах України лідирують чинні мери.
А висуванці від "Слуги народу" в багатьох із них навіть не потрапляють у другий тур.
Схожа ситуація і з виборами депутатів міських рад: у таких мегаполісах, як Київ, Харків, Одеса та Дніпро,
"Слуга народу" - лише на третьому місці.
Партію Зеленського там випередили такі політсили, як УДАР Віталія Кличка, "Європейська Солідарність" Петра Порошенка,
"Блок Кернеса - Успішний Харків!", пов'язана з мером Одеси Геннадієм Трухановим "Довіряй ділам" та ОПЗЖ.
Для політолога Володимира Фесенка такий результат не став несподіванкою.
Навпаки, втрата значної підтримки - радше закономірність, вважає експерт.
Це обумовлено тим, що реформа децентралізації спрацювала насамперед на користь партій місцевих інтересів.
Друга причина - є певне розчарування. В умовах нинішньої економічної кризи і пандемії
поразка партії "Слуга народу" достатньо обумовлена.
Тим більше, що минулого року був аномальний результат. Те, що у нас відбулося минулого року,
- це теж була криза довіри до еліт, але тоді це спрацювало на користь Зеленського і його партії "Слуга народу".
А нині така ж криза довіри до політичних еліт спрацювала вже на користь місцевих партій.
Натомість для президента Зеленського скромний результат його партії став, вочевидь, холодним душем.
У неділю ввечері глава держави у соцмережах різко відреагував на результати екзитполів:
пообіцяв "жорстко стежити" за новообраною місцевою владою.
Утім, вважає політолог Володимир Фесенко, дезінтеграції боятися не варто.
За нашою традицією, після виборів місцеві еліти, як правило, починають домовлятися з центральною владою
- не конфронтувати з нею, а домовлятися.
Я наведу приклад: Кернес і Труханов, мери Харкова і Одеси, свого часу домовилися з Порошенком,
хоча ідеологічно були його опонентами.
Велика загроза для національної безпеки України була б у разі перемоги в російськомовних регіонах проросійських партій -
це ОПЗЖ і партія Шарія.
Але на цей час ми бачимо, що ОПЗЖ хоча і серед переможців, але не має тотальної перемоги.
Головні переможці - це місцеві партії, партії мерів міст.
Крім не вельми втішних результатів для "Слуги народу" і ОПЗЖ та успіху чинних мерів
ще одна особливість нинішніх місцевих виборів - історично низька явка.
За попередніми даними, проголосувати за мерів і місцевих депутатів прийшли лише 37 відсотків виборців.
Одна з причин - страх заразитися коронавірусом, пояснив DW член однієї з київських виборчих комісій.
Страх перед коронавірусом. Також люди просто вважають вибори цих депутатів не дуже важливими і значущими для себе
- на відміну від виборів депутатів Верховної Ради і президента.
Ми протираємо руки, ноги, столи - я жартую трошки. Тобто ми вживаємо всіх протиепідеміологічних заходів.
Ті ж виборці, хто попри "ковід" прийшли проголосувати, кажуть,
що ризик заразитися на виборчій дільниці не більший, ніж деінде.
Ми не боїмося захворіти, тому що ми кожного дня їздимо в переповненому транспорті,
заходимо до торговельних центрів, ходимо на роботу. Тут ризик мінімальний.
Ні, я не боялась. Маску ось одягла. Ми ж ходимо в магазини, кругом - життя продовжується.
Утім, епідемія коронавірусу не зупинила президента Володимира Зеленського
провести ще й "загальнонаціональне опитування" з п'яти питань.
Опозиція і експерти піддали цю ініціативу нищівній критиці - на їхню думку, це опитування було нічим іншим,
як партійною агітацією, яка у день виборів заборонена.
Через різко негативне ставлення до імпровізованого "референдуму" МВС навіть закликало українців
не бити волонтерів-інтерв'юерів, котрі, як виявилося, працювали зовсім не на громадських засадах.
Ніхто не чіпає, все добре, чудово.
- Самі проголосували?
Ні, ще не встигла. Робота.
- Ви студентка? Так. - Скільки вам платять? - Я не можу вам дати цю інформацію. Я вибачаюся. Я працюю. Це моя робота.
Питали українців про те, що вони думають про довічне ув'язнення за корупцію в особливо великих розмірах,
скорочення кількості депутатів Верховної Ради до 300, вільну економічну зону на Донбасі,
Будапештський меморандум та легалізацію канабісу в медичних цілях.
Чи приніс такий креатив від Зеленського додаткові голоси його партії - невідомо.
А от результати опитування в жодному разі не є репрезентативними, застерігають експерти.
Серед іншого й через те, що проголосувати за бажанням можна було кілька разів,
а так звані "бюлетені" не мали жодного захисту.